okay meanwhile and some actual good news
the
coveted vaccine is going out on mass
today
tons of doses going out today which is
excellent excellent news of course
and um the bioentec head you've worked
on the
worked on the vaccine he says that we
should be getting back to normal by the
end of next summer because at that point
all the vaccines are out there and life
is what life is
we know that we have a solution yeah and
we know that we can produce many doses
of vaccines and we know that there
will be also other vaccines which have
shown efficacy
and therefore therefore people
we should be confident that we can we
will be able to control this disease and
the pandemic
latest end of next summer that is dr
uger
sahin who is one of the heads of
bioentech which worked with pfizer to
develop the vaccine
2.9 million doses of cova 19 vaccine are
beginning to arrive
uh a lot of those are going to the most
populous places in the country
so first in line are 17 million
healthcare workers and 3.7 million
nursing home residents
and then you get essential workers
teachers first responders and then you
get
89 million people with pre-existing
conditions now here's the thing i think
that probably we should actually be
working on people with pre-existing
conditions first if you're an essential
worker
but you're 25 years old and healthy you
really should not be in line before
somebody who is 65 years old and has
serious preexisting conditions so the
tranching doesn't make
a whole hell of a lot of sense
nonetheless
uh this is the way that the distribution
is going to go
and the number of doses varies fairly
widely by state
in the early going california is about
to get 330 000 doses colorado is going
to get 47 000 doses
but smaller states are going to get far
fewer delaware only gets about 9
000 doses florida gets 180 000 doses
so the the vaccines have begun to roll
out that is a massive win
for the trump administration the media
however
are suggesting that it is the trump
administration's fault that people are
skeptical about about the vaccine
because there's a lot of questions about
who wants to take the vaccine
and let me be clear the vaccine in terms
of the studies has been proved to be
effective
does that mean that children should be
getting it probably not at least not as
at first blush they should be like last
in line
number one because they're at least risk
of this thing and number two because
they're the least likely to transmit
this thing or have intergenerational
contact with people
who are elderly as i say we should be
tranching this thing out
and you know people should be able to
assess their own
level of risk when it comes to getting
the thing versus not getting the thing
or damage if you do get the thing as
opposed to not getting the thing if
you're
17 years old and you're not only
unlikely to die of this thing it's less
likely to kill you than the flu
you may be like well not trump into it
that's understandable
with that said the widespread vaccine
skepticism that has now cropped up on
the left is clearly a product of the
media hating trump
now the media are going to turn around
try and blame trump for the vaccine
skepticism they themselves created
on msnbc here we go they were blaming
trump for blue state vaccine skepticism
yeah yes but unfortunately this happened
because of just the
horrible precedent that got set by
the president and members of the trump
administration
to politicize a number of treatments
and even some of the efforts leading to
a vaccine to this point
okay that is dr kavita patel a former
obama official obviously so it's about
politicization
never mind the fact that everybody in
the process says the process was never
politicized
in fact the united states lagged behind
two other countries the uk and canada
where the third country to actually
approve the distribution of the vaccine
here's the fda chief in fact saying
external pressure was not the issue in
us
deciding to greenlight this thing jake
we have been very clear and and i'll say
it again here
that nothing guided our decision no
external comments
no external pressure other than the
science and data guided
our decision making if you look at the
timetable here
immediately after the vaccine advisory
committee
our team spent that night we decided to
go forward and you know by early morning
before 7 a.m
we issued a statement saying that we
were moving forward working with pfizer
to get the authorization out
and then we worked throughout today to
do that our timeline
how we approached this was based upon
our thorough review
of the science and data that's the
promise we made the american people
the transparency around that and that's
what we did so we're just going to
whitewash completely the fact that
andrew cuomo and kamala harris and a
bunch of democrats were casting
absolute doubt on the efficacy of the
vaccine developed under the trump
administration instead we're going to
pretend
that it was trump putting pressure on
the fda i mean like the media's
malfeasance with regard to covet
is the reason that people have serious
covet trust issues with regard to
solving this thing another reason
is because there are so many people who
seem to be in the media eager to shut
this thing down i mean just
super eager to shut down the economy
like really eager
to talk about how bad things are going
to be for years on end so
bill gates who is giving a lot of money
to the development of vaccines like this
one
bill gates went on national tv with jake
tapper where he explained that
life would not return to normal through
2022 and then we should not open bars
and restaurants
for four to six months that's easy for
bill gates to say he's one of the
richest people on earth how about the
people who actually own those
restaurants
2022 are you kidding me here's how this
is actually gonna work once the vaccines
go
out and once we've given the possibility
of dosing to everybody
everybody's going back to work and
people are not going to wear masks
they're not going to do it forever
they're not that interested in doing
this for a long time
they're just not it's not going to
happen but the the sort of
blithe dismissal bill gates has for
normality is pretty incredible
of course it's easy to do that when
you're you know jetting around on
private jets and living on private
islands
here's bill gates certainly by the
summer
we'll be way closer to normal than we
are now
but even through early 2022 unless we
help other countries
get rid of this disease and we get high
vaccination rates in our country
the risk of reintroduction will be there
and of course
the global economy will be uh slowed
down which hurts
america economically in a pretty
dramatic way
so we'll have starting in the summer
about nine months where a few things
like big public gatherings
uh will still be restricted but
you know we can see now that somewhere
between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well to get back to normal nope
wrong watch once everybody has the
opportunity to get vaccinated
and then the people who want to do we're
going back to normal
okay and nobody's going to pay attention
to what bill gates has to say about any
of this
and this is true with regard to asking
it is true with regard to everyday
activity nobody is going to stay away
from their families
by the way a huge percentage of these
spread is not in public events it is
family gatherings
so if we are it's not it's not these big
super spreader events that are the real
danger
really it is people who have coveted
going back home to mom and dad people
are not going to put off life
for another two years not happening not
happening
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content